>> I DON'T WANT TO HAVE 100
GUARDS STANDING WITH RIFLES ALL
OVER THE SCHOOL.
YOU DO A CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT.
BUT WE REALLY DO HAVE TO
STRENGTHEN UP, REALLY STRENGTHEN
UP BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE THAT ARE
MENTALLY ILL TO BE HAVING ANY
FORM OF WEAPONRY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE BEING TOTALLY
UNRESPONSIVE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT DACA.
I'M TELLING YOU.
AND IT'S VERY POSSIBLE THAT DACA
WON'T HAPPEN.
NORTH KOREA, WE IMPOSED TODAY
THE HEAVIEST SANCTIONS EVER
IMPOSED ON A COUNTRY BEFORE.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP AT CPAC
TODAY.
THAT SPEECH WAS LIKE CATNIP FOR
THAT CROWD.
IT WAS THE LET TRUMP BE TRUMP
ESSENTIALLY THE FOLKS WHO SAY HE
NEEDS TO BE UNPLUGGED AND DO
THOSE CAMPAIGN SPEECHES.
THEY WON THE DAY.
BECAUSE HE DID.
AND IT WAS AN HOUR AND 14
MINUTES.
THERE WAS A LOT TO UNPACK IN
THAT SPEECH.
AND OTHER NEWS TODAY, BUT ONE OF
THE BIG ITEMS WAS NORTH KOREA'S
SANCTIONS AND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
HERE'S THE TREASURY SECRETARY.
>> OUR ACTIONS TARGET SHIPPING
AND TRADE COMPANIES.
VESSELS AND INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE WORLD WHO WE KNOW ARE
WORKING ON NORTH KOREA'S BEHALF
AND WE ARE ISSUING A GLOBAL
SHIPPING ADVISORY IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE COAST GUARD AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TO PUT EVERYONE
ON NOTICE OF NORTH KOREA'S
ILLICIT MARITIME TACTICS AND
UNDERSCORE THE SIGNIFICANT
SANCTIONS RISK OF ENGAGING IN
MARITIME BUSINESS WITH NORTH
KOREA.
>> IT'S ALREADY THE MOST
SANCTIONED COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
NOW MORE SO FROM THE U.S. POINT
OF VIEW.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL, BYRON
YORK, CHIEF POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT OF "THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER".
A.B. STABBED ORDER, HOST OF NO
LABELS RADIO ON SIRIUS XM.
AND JASON RILEY.
LET'S START WITH NORTH KOREA.
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENT TONE BIG
MOVE TODAY?
>> NOT TO HEAR THE PRESIDENT'S
SPEECH.
THIS WAS A VERY, VERY TRUMPY
SPEECH AND IT WENT ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
AND THE EXTRAORDINARY THING
ABOUT THE NORTH KOREA PART OF
THE SPEECH IS HE ALMOST FORGOT
TO PUT IT IN.
>> Bret: THE WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS WERE TOUTING IT THIS
MORNING.
HERE IT COMES.
>> EXACTLY.
IN THE LEADUP TO THE SPEECH,
THEY WERE SAYING THIS IS GOING
TO BE THE BIG NEWS.
YOU LISTEN AND AN HOUR GOES BY,
HOUR 10 MINUTES AND HE'S
WRAPPING UP ABOUT TO SAY
GOOD-BYE AND SAYS, OH, NORTH
KOREA.
WE'RE GOING TO IMPOSE REALLY
STRONG SANCTIONS.
GOOD-BYE, EVERYBODY.
BUT THEY ARE SERIOUS IN THE
SENSE THAT THIS IS ANOTHER STEP.
AND WE OFTEN HEAR THAT WE'VE
DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN TO NORTH
KOREA.
WE REALLY HAVEN'T AND THESE ARE
ADDITIONAL SANCTIONS THAT MIGHT
HAVE AN EFFECT.
>> IT ALSO COMES AS IVANKA TRUMP
LANDS IN SOUTH KOREA WITH A
SPECIFIC MESSAGE, OBVIOUSLY
TODAY WITH THIS SANCTIONS
LEVYING AS MIKE PENCE, THE VICE
PRESIDENT DID NOT HAVE A MEETING
WITH THE NORTH KOREAENS WHEN HE
WAS THERE.
>> THE TIMING IS NO ACCIDENT.
IVANKA TRUMP IS THERE AND BEING
HOSTED BY THE PRESIDENT MOON
FROM SOUTH KOREA THAT HAS BEEN
TRYING TO ENGAGE THE NORTH.
I THINK THE MESSAGE FROM THE
NORTH IS ENGAGEMENT OR NO
ENGAGEMENT, OLYMPICS OR NO
OLYMPICS, WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PUT PRESSURE ON
NORTH KOREA.
AND WE SAW LAST WEEK HOW THE
MEDIA WENT GAGA OVER THE NORTH
KOREAN LEADER'S SISTER BEING AT
THE OLYMPICS AND SO FORTH.
TRUMP WAS SAYING I DON'T CARE
ABOUT THAT.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS WE DON'T
CARE ABOUT THAT EITHER.
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT THOSE
APPEARANCES.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS REGIME
TRYING TO BECOME A NUCLEAR POWER
AND WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE
PRESSURE ON.
>> Bret: WE HAVEN'T SEEN
SANCTIONS MOVE THE NEEDLE THAT
MUCH.
WE HAVE SEEN SOME MOVEMENT IN
CHINA.
BUT NOT AS MUCH AS THE U.S.
WANTS TO SEE.
BUT IS THIS GOING TO WORK?
>> WELL, IT'S ALWAYS THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT THESE
ARE ENFORCEABLE.
AND THE REGIME IN NORTH KOREA
HAS SO MANY WAYS TO CRIMINAL
CONDUCT TO DO RUN-AROUNDS AND
WORK AROUNDS OF MOST OF THE
SANCTIONS.
RIGHT NOW, THEY'RE UNDER
PRESSURE FROM SANCTIONS ON OIL
SO THIS IS WHY WE'RE GOING AFTER
THE SHIPPING INDUSTRY TO SEE
WHAT KIND OF WORK AROUNDS THEY
HAVE GOING THERE.
THERE'S ALWAYS ANOTHER COUNTRY
THAT'S WILLING TO HELP THEM IN
THE DARK OF NIGHT.
THE CHINESE.
I THINK WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS GOTTEN THE CHINESE TO DO SO
FAR IF ENFORCED IS VERY
CONSEQUENTIAL.
THIS IS VERY AGGRESSIVE.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD ALL GIVE
THEM A LOT OF CREDIT FOR THAT.
THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S ENFORCEABLE
AND ULTIMATELY CONSEQUENTIAL, WE
DON'T KNOW.
>> Bret: YOU MENTIONED HE DID
HAVE HIS CAMPAIGN MOJO TODAY.
DOESN'T FIT EVERYBODY'S CUP OF
TEA BUT DEFINITELY FITS IT WITH
THE CPAC FOLKS AND SUPPORTERS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE COUNTRY ESPECIALLY
THOSE STATES.
HERE HE IS ON ARMED GUARDS, DID
NOTHING EARLIER IN THE DAY.
TALKING ABOUT DOWN IN FLORIDA.
>> WHEN IT CAME TIME TO GET IN
THERE AND DO SOMETHING, HE
DIDN'T HAVE THE COURAGE OR
SOMETHING HAPPENED BUT HE
CERTAINLY DID A POOR JOB.
>> I'D RATHER HAVE SOMEBODY THAT
LOVES THIS -- THEIR STUDENTS AND
WANTS TO PROTECT THEIR STUDENTS
THAN SOMEBODY OUTSIDE HA DOESN'T
KNOW ANYBODY AND DOESN'T KNOW
THE STUDENTS, THE TEACHERS AND
THE COACHES AND OTHER PEOPLE IN
THE BUILDING, THE DEAN, THE
ASSISTANT DEAN, THE PRINCIPAL,
THEY CAN -- THEY LOVE THEIR
PEOPLE.
THEY WANT TO PROTECT THESE KIDS.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THAT'S CLASSIC TRUMP
COMMUNICATION.
ON GUNS, HE DID TALK ABOUT
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
HE TALKED ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND THE ONE THING HE
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT IS SOMETHING
HE'S BEEN SAYING THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS IS RAISING THE AGE TO
BUY A LONG GUN TO EQUAL THAT OF
BUYING A HANDGUN.
YOU HAD TO BE 21 TO BUY A
HANDGUN.
YOU CAN BUY A LONG GUN LIKE THE
AR-15 AT 18.
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT RAISING THAT
TO 21.
THE N.R.A. DOESN'T LIKE IT BUT
THE PRESIDENT HAS SPECIFICALLY
SAID IN THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS
THAT HE DOES LIKE THE IDEA.
BUT HE SAID NOTHING ABOUT IT OUT
OF THIS HOUR AND 14 MINUTES
SPEECH.
>> Bret: JASON?
>> I THINK HE HAS A GOOD POINT
ABOUT THE GUN-FREE ZONES AND THE
MASS SHOOTERS TARGETING US.
THERE'S A REASON THAT YOU DON'T
GET A LOT OF MASS SHOOTINGS AT
N.R.A. CONVENTIONS, FOR EXAMPLE,
EVEN AMONG MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE.
THEY SEEM TO KNOW BETTER.
THERE IS SOMETHING TO THAT.
THE BACKGROUND CHECK THING, I
THINK THERE'S BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR THAT.
RAISING THE AGE, I THINK THE
N.R.A. HAS A GOOD POINT HERE.
A LOT OF THESE MASS SHOOTERS
THAT ARE UNDER AGE USE THEIR
PARENTS' WEAPONS OR FIND OTHER
ADULTS.
THAT WAS THE CASE IN SANDY HOOK.
I'M NOT SURE THAT IS GOING TO BE
A BIG GAME CHANGER.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE IS A VERY REAL ONE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF -- HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF GUNS OUT THERE.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING INTO THE RIGHT HANDS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
F.B.I. AND THE OTHER
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES HAVE
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE TO RESPOND TO
THE RED FLAGS WHEN WE GET THEM.
AND THERE WAS DEFINITELY A
FAILURE ON HIS PART.
>> Bret: QUICKLY, WE TALKED
ABOUT IT ALL WEEK WHAT CONGRESS
WILL OR WON'T DO.
MOSTLY ON THE WON'T.
>> LET'S LOOK AT THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A DIFFERENT
PLAN FOR THE CROWD AT CPAC THAN
HE DOES EARLIER IN THE WEEK.
BY THE TIME CONGRESS COMES BACK
NEXT WEEK, I THINK THE PRESIDENT
WILL STICK ON SCHOOL SAFETY AND
NOT BE TALKING ABOUT
COMPREHENSIVE BACKGROUND CHECKS
WHICH THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
HE'S TALKING ABOUT.
UNTIL AND WHEN HE WANTS TO PUSH
FOR SOMETHING LIKE A NEW AGE
RESTRICTION, I DON'T THINK HE'S
MAKING IT CLEAR WHAT HE'S REALLY
WILLING TO GIVE ON.
AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE
UNLESS PUSHED BY THIS PRESIDENT.
IT IS ON HIM TO LEAD THE
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE IN AN ELECTION YEAR AND
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO DO THIS.
UNLESS HE INSISTS ON IT.
>> Bret: HE POTENTIALLY COULD